Allah gives the solution for happiness
and the best is if you
read the
book 70 major sin hadith of the prophet
that there are seven major sins Abbas
says may Allah be pleased with him 70 is
more closer to seven 70 major sin and
this are the major dos and don'ts Allah
says in the Quran you stay away from
major sins Allah will forgive your minor
sins I'll just point out a few of the
major dos and don'ts Time is limited.
Number
one is number one
is dos and don'ts in the kabay dos and
don'ts are mixed means if you do shik it
is the biggest sin. So number one do
is believing in
Allah and the biggest sin is
shik associating partners with Allah
subhana wa tala. So in chapter 4 verse
48. So in Isisa chapter 4 116. Allah may
forgive any sin if he pleases. But the
sin of he'll never
forgive the number to do it is
salah your prayers. And our beloved
prophet said the difference between im
and kuf is
salah. The person the thing that
differentiates a m and a kafir a muslim
and a non-Muslim is salah. Number three
is zakat. Every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level of
85 grams of gold should give 2.5% in
charity every lunar
year. Number four is fasting in the
month of Ramadan. Abstaining from food,
drink and sex from dawn up to sunset in
the month of Ramadan. Hajj if you have
the means perform
Hajj. Next is obeying and respecting
your parents. Surra 17:23 says that if
one or both of your parents reach old
age don't say off to
them amongst the thing which is haram
first again
shik if you do dawa if you don't remove
the shake from the mind of a non-Muslim
your dawa is useless number two today
the biggest killer of happiness you have
wars all over the world you have America
Afghanistan killing hundreds of
thousands of people, attacking Iraq,
weapons of mass destruction,
fabrication, killing millions. What is
Israel doing in Gaza? More than 45,000
people killed. Most of them are children
and women. That's
also recorded. Not recorded, multiple
times more. More than 100,000 seriously
injured. What's happening in Roindia?
What's happening in Bangladesh? Shina
killed thousands of Muslims. What's
happening in India? Muslims are being
lynched. What's happening in China? One
solution. Allah says in surah Maida
chapter 5 verse number 32, if anyone
kills any other human being, unless it
be for murder or corruption, it is as
though he has killed the whole of
humanity. And if anyone saves an human
being, he saved the whole of humanity.
If any Muslim or non-Muslim kills any
other innocent Muslim or non-Muslim, it
is as though you have killed the whole
of humanity. If this worse every human
being follows, terrorism will be
eradicated from this world. And if you
save a human being, you are saving the
whole of
humanity. Number three, black
magic. Number four, zena, adultery,
fornication. Allah says in surah chapter
number 17 verse number 32, come not
close to adultery or fornication because
it's an evil opening other roads to
evil.
Next is ribba. In the major sin,
fornication is number 10 in Imm
Abdhabi's book of Kabar. Number 12 is
ribba. Allah says in surah bakar chapter
2 verse number 278 and 279, if you give
up not your demands of interest of
ribba, take notice of a war from Allah
and
hisul. If you have alcohol, Allah
doesn't wage a war against you. If you
take ribba, give or take ribba, Allah
will wage a war against you. Do you have
the guts or the capacity to fight Allah
and
his and Allah says alcohol is prohibited
in 5 verse number
90 oh you
believe oh you believe most certainly
toxic innoc and gambling dedication of
stone divination of arrows these are
Satan's handiwork abstain from it that
you may prosper this was in brief about
dos and don'ts the
solution for happiness. I would like to
end my speech with the same verse of the
Quran. I started surah alsar chapter
number 103 verse number 123 which says
Man is very in a state of floss except
those who have faith, those who have
righteous deed, those who exalt people
to truth and those who exalt people to
patience and pursuits.